welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousin sitting in for david
pakman today you can find me on social
media on both twitter facebook and of
course instagram as well
at
farron balanced you can get me on
youtube youtube.com the ring of fire and
youtube.com slash
farron balanced
we've got more to talk about with
afghanistan and you know not to be
outdone from all of the stupid takes
going on out there about afghanistan
marjorie taylor greene
comes out
with one of the most absurd and quite
possibly disgusting
takes on what is happening in the
country and without further ado folks
i am going to let marjorie taylor green
say it in her own words here she is an
interview from sunday with steve bannon
take it away congressman marjorie taylor
green uh you've heard what president
trump says do you agree with that given
your assessments a pretty big that's a
pretty big ask for a president to resign
about something like this do you agree
with that
absolutely as a matter of fact i have my
team uh right now working on articles of
impeachment because i'm so disgusted
with joe biden you know i've already
filed one set of articles of impeachment
but but his uh failure as a president is
is unspeakable there's reporting that
the u.s is paying a vast sum of cash to
the taliban in exchange for allowing the
evacuation to proceed is this true
now she can't verify that i know what's
going around um
give us your thoughts on that even the
mention of that is pretty stunning
what are your thoughts on this and what
are you hearing
i can't verify that either so i won't
say if it's true or not unless i had
direct proof of it but i would not doubt
it look at the way president biden has
the american military basically running
scared out of afghanistan and they were
begging the taliban to give them time
and wait until they could evacuate from
the airport and so i'm i wouldn't be
surprised at all if they were paying the
taliban after all they're already paying
them with weapons vehicles blackhawk
helicopters because the afghan harmony
army is handing them over as fast as
possible wouldn't be surprised to learn
even though
as bannon mentioned yeah i mean there's
no evidence of this
marjorie taylor green says yeah i mean
there's no evidence of it but let's
pretend there is and say oh i bet it's
happening
that's that's that's how republican lies
grow i hope you realize what we just
witnessed there folks
that was the birth
of a talking point
it's a stupid talking point
again there's no evidence to suggest
that that's what's happening
but why should that stop them
from just making stuff up
about what's really taking place and by
the way
a little part of that clip in the in the
in the full clip um
if anybody wants to go and watch it it's
it's terrible but bannon actually
mentioned he got those questions
from republican congresswoman elise
stefanik's office
so yeah just to let you know like how
staged all this crap really is
stefanik's office sent those questions
over to him
i guess
in an attempt to get margaery taylor
green to say something stupid which of
course she never disappoints with that
in case you're wondering
what's really happening right now is yes
the united states has in fact worked out
a deal with the taliban
to where they will not
attack the airport in kabul
so that they can continue to get
refugees out of the country
i'm sure by now most people have seen
some of the footage
of the people desperate to flee the
country literally climbing on top of
airplanes
i i believe at least
half a dozen or more people have been
killed
literally being run over by airplanes on
the runway to the point where on monday
they actually had to call it off they
couldn't have any more flights because
the airport was being flooded with
people trying to leave the country
so the administration came out had to
try to work out this deal
which they discussed over in i believe
it's dohar
so they worked out this deal and said
listen you have to let us get people out
of here
you have to let us get these refugees
you have to promise to not attack this
airport otherwise they said the general
who you know helped work out this deal
if you attack the airport you're going
to be met with you know the swift fury
of the united states military so let us
get people out
and we will not attack you
there was no indication that money
changed hands there was no
obvious as she pointed out uh exchange
of weapons
and i believe
if i may try to make sense of what
marjorie taylor green is saying the
fact that she's talking about oh we're
giving them weapons no we're not
let's be clear about that
as far as i've seen and feel free to
correct me if i'm wrong but i don't know
that the united states has made a deal
to give the taliban weapons
what we have seen
is that they have raided
the afghan military's weaponry which yes
is full of weapons that the united
states gave them
so i guess if you want to consider that
the united states giving weapons to
these individuals then
you know it's a roundabout way of saying
it it's obviously not exactly true but
technically sure i mean well i guess i
guess you could say that the united
states gave them weapons
because we gave it to these people who
then abandoned it and it was taken over
by the taliban
so
maybe we need to stop giving all these
weapons to people overseas i don't know
that sounds like a pretty easy solution
heck we could probably cut down the
military budget the pentagon budget
every year if we didn't do that so you
actually accidentally just made a really
great case marjorie taylor green
for not continuing to send united states
weapons
overseas
i i think that's a good plan and if
that's where you really want to go
marjorie i'm with you 100 percent i
would love to see the united states no
longer sending our weapons of death
all over the planet
as i'm sure a lot of people on the left
would agree with me on that
but again
it is just remarkable to see them
you know in the early stages of a new
talking point like biden's paying them
off there's no evidence to suggest it
but we probably think that it's
something that could likely maybe happen
you know it's not impossible it's a
plausible idea so let's just push it
and see if the public buys into that
narrative
that's how they operate they don't have
to have facts
they don't have to have evidence
when you're a republican talking head or
a republican politician whatever you can
make up
is what sticks
and that becomes the narrative
that they run with i'm really excited
that uh one of our sponsors today is
helix sleep i sleep on a helix mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why i reached out to them about
sponsoring the david pakman show buying
a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video